en este vídeo vamos a hablar acerca de
la hibridación sp3 ese es el estado de
hibridación del carbono en esta molécula
de metano si quisiera dibujar la
estructura de puntos de esta molécula lo
que haría es tomar el carbono y sabemos
que el carbono tiene 4 electrones de
valencia y los dibujos por aquí y que
cada uno de estos hidrógenos tiene un
electrón de valencia entonces podemos
poner por aquí un hidrógeno con su
electrón de valencia y estos dos
electrones van a formar un enlace
covalente simple y por aquí otro
hidrógeno
y listo y cada uno de estos pares de
electrones de valencia está formando un
enlace covalente y tenemos aquí en
nuestra molécula de metano ahora todos
estos enlaces son enlaces equivalentes
entonces todos estos electrones de
valencia del carbono también deberían de
ser equivalentes entonces tenemos que
ver la configuración electrónica del
carbono y vamos a utilizar la anotación
de los orbitales tenemos aquí en este
eje de la izquierda los distintos
niveles de energía en orden ascendente
en el primer nivel tenemos el orbital 1
s en el segundo nivel de energía tenemos
el orbital 2s y también en el segundo
nivel de energía tenemos a los 3
orbitales de tipo 2 p aunque ahí tenemos
1 2 3 aunque todo esto está en el
segundo nivel de energía y el carbono
tiene 6 electrones
además estos electrones se llenan
primero llenando los niveles de energía
más bajos o sea que tenemos que poner
por aquí dos electrones que llenan al
orbital 1s después vamos a general
orbital 2s y finalmente nos quedan dos
elecciones que van en los orbitales 2 p
de esta forma entonces si estoy tratando
de identificar los 4 electrones de
valencia que son los electrones que
hacen los enlaces estos electrones son
los que tienen el mayor nivel de energía
que en este caso es todo el segundo
nivel ok
allí si estas tres órbitas tienen más
energía que la órbita 12 pero se
encuentran en el mismo nivel de energía
que es el segundo nivel de energía
entonces estos cuatro electrones de aquí
son los que estamos representando en la
estructura de puntos aquí son estos
pero electrones el problema es que en
esta representación de los orbitales
tenemos únicamente dos orbitales libres
únicamente estos dos electrones no
tienen otro electrón girando en su misma
órbita con el espín contrario y esto
implicaría que el carbono solo debería
de formar dos enlaces sin embargo
sabemos que eso no es cierto o sea por
aquí tenemos el metano donde claramente
el carbono hace cuatro enlaces y no
únicamente dos entonces tenemos que
encontrar una forma de hacer que estos
cuatro electrones sean equivalentes con
respecto a su nivel de energía porque
pues aunque todos estén en el segundo
nivel de energía estos electrones tienen
más energía que estos y además que estén
todos estos electrones solitos y tienen
que estar solitos para que cada uno
pueda hacer un enlace con algún
hidrógeno y así el carbono si puede
hacer cuatro enlaces al químico online
por link se le ocurrió una forma en la
que cuatro órbitas pueden ser
equivalentes
lo primero que dijo el line sporting fue
vamos a darle un poquito de energía a
uno de estos electrones que están en la
órbita 2s y con esa energía pues vamos a
moverlo a la órbita 2p gay eso fue lo
primero que se le ocurrió y entonces ya
tendríamos 4 electrones solitos y por lo
tanto el carbono ya podría hacer 4
enlaces el único problema es que estos 4
electrones no son equivalentes y por lo
tanto sus enlaces tampoco van a ser
equivalentes ok lo que necesitamos es
que estos 4 electrones estén en el mismo
nivel de energía y entonces al inews
pauli se le ocurrió y propuso el
concepto de hibridación y dijo qué
pasaría si tomamos este orbital 2s y le
subimos un poquito la energía y entonces
lo movemos a este nivel de energía
y luego a estos tres orbitales 2p les
bajamos un poco la energía y entonces
los movemos a este nivel de energía
y ponemos un electrón en cada una de
estas órbitas ahora lo que hay que tomar
en cuenta es que estos orbitales ya no
son los orbitales que teníamos antes o
sea este orbital ya no va a ser un
orbital de tipo 12 ese ahora va a ser un
orbital híbrido de tipo sp kubica y lo
mismo con estos estos tampoco van a ser
orbitales de tipo 2 pero ahora van a ser
orbitales de tipo esp kubica
y estos nuevos orbitales que hemos
formado pues se parecen en un 25% al
orbital ese y en un 75% a un orbital p y
se llaman orbitales sp3 justo porque
para formar los tomamos a un orbital de
tipo s ya tres orbitales de tipo p y los
mezclamos y salieron estos cuatro
orbitales a los que llamamos orbitales
híbridos sp3 y ahora si esta estructura
de puntos de luís del carbono que
estábamos dibujando y la realidad de lo
que hemos observado que el carbono hace
cuatro enlaces si coincide con lo que
tenemos aquí que son cuatro orbitales
equivalentes con un electrón libre en
cada una de ellas
entonces estos orbitales híbridos sp3
tienen una naturaleza que es 25% de tipo
s y los orbitales de tipo s son como una
esfera o la cáscara de una esfera y un
75% de tipo p y los orbitales pesan como
mancuernas ok tenemos aquí el núcleo y
tenemos aquí una mancuerna y entonces
las cuentas que se hacen con los números
cuánticos que son muy complicadas y que
no vale la pena verlas con detalle en
este vídeo pero estas cuentas con los
números cuánticos nos dicen cómo es la
forma de estos nuevos orbitales híbridos
que son como una mancuerna pero con un
lado mucho más grande que el otro ahora
cuando estamos dibujando estos orbitales
para que los dibujos no se vean tan feos
lo que vamos a hacer es no pintar este
lado del orbital y nada más pintar este
lado grandote
entonces vamos a volver a dibujar este
carbono pero ahora vamos a dibujar sus
orbitales
ya sabemos que este carbono cuando hace
estos cuatro enlaces sus órbitas y brie
dicen y se vuelven orbitales del tipo
sp3 y lo vamos a dibujar por acá así es
que tenemos al carbono bueno el núcleo
del carbono
4 orbitales híbridos esp 3 y además
estamos en la tercera dimensión entonces
digamos que este es el centro y estos
tres orbitales están saltando un poquito
hacia la pantalla y bueno el siguiente
orbital pues vamos a imaginar que se
está clavando hacia adentro de la
pantalla pero pues es más fácil
dibujarlo por aquí y además en este
dibujo no estoy dibujando este pedacito
chiquito de la mancuerna que es la forma
en la que tiene cada uno de estos
orbitales y que hay aquí habría una
bolita y otra bolita y así como tenemos
aquí en cada uno de estos orbitales
híbridos hay un electrón ok aquí
nuestros cuatro electrones de valencia
del carbono que son estos cuatro
electrones en sus órbita civilidad sp3 y
como estamos viendo la molécula del
metano estos cuatro electrones - en un
enlace con un hidrógeno cada uno y
sabemos que el hidrógeno tiene
únicamente un electrón por lo tanto
su único electrón es sube electrón de
valencia que se encuentra en el primer
nivel de energía o sea que tiene una
órbita de tipo 1s las cuales son
circulares ok entonces aquí está el
electrón del hidrógeno que hace un
enlace con este electrón del carbono y
pues eso sucede con cada uno de los
orbitales
del carbono
y entonces así es como se ven los
orbitales
pero bueno repito este carbono sus
orbitales son orbitales híbridos sp3 y
por lo mismo que son orbitales híbridos
sp3 y que son equivalentes
entonces estos orbitales están en una
forma de tripié ok y por lo tanto los
hidrógenos que están enlazando se formen
un tetraedro y bueno esta estructura de
tetraedro que tiene esta molécula se da
porque estas órbitas híbridas sp3 son
todas equivalentes y son cuatro órbitas
entonces vamos a ver en el próximo vídeo
que el ángulo de enlace entre todas
estas moléculas es ciento 9.5 grados y
ahora construye monos en cómo se
intersectan los hidrógenos con el
carbono y pues nos podemos fijar en que
aquí estos orbitales se intersectan y la
intersección está entre los núcleos de
estos dos átomos
entonces a eso le llamamos un enlace
enlace sigma
y esta sigma es la letra griega sigma
aquí en este otro enlace también podemos
ver que la intersección de los dos
orbitales está entre los núcleos de los
dos átomos entonces también es un enlace
sigma al igual que por aquí
por acá entonces el metano tiene cuatro
enlaces sigma muy bien entonces este es
el dibujo de los orbitales de la
molécula metano
y ahora vamos a ver rápidamente el
dibujo de los orbitales del etano
entonces vamos a poner la estructura de
puntos de louis del etano tenemos dos
carbonos enlazados y luego cada uno de
esos carbonos tiene tres hidrógenos aquí
están los hidrógenos
entonces tenemos 2 carbonos y 6
hidrógenos así es que la fórmula del
etano es c 2 h 6 vimos aquí que cuando
tenemos un enlace simple entonces lo que
tenemos es un enlace sigma y entonces si
queremos saber cuál es la cantidad de
enlaces sigmas que tiene el etano lo que
tenemos que hacer es contar cuántos
enlaces simples tiene podemos ver que
tiene 12
cuatro cinco seis siete enlaces simples
y por lo tanto tiene siete enlaces sigma
y si queremos hacer un dibujo como éste
pues no es que piense un poquito a ver
sabemos que este carbono está abril
izado y es un carbón híbrido sp3 al
igual que este otro carbón también es un
carbón híbrido sp3 sabemos esto porque
tiene cuatro enlaces queréis siempre que
un carbón tenga puros enlaces simples
ningún enlace doble o triple los
orbitales de ese carbón son orbitales
híbridos de la forma sp3 y tenemos puros
enlaces simples si y sólo si el carbono
tiene cuatro enlaces como sucede por
aquí bueno entonces ya para hacer un
dibujo como estos vamos a poner a un
carbono por aquí que tiene sus cuatro
orbitales híbridos sp3 entonces vamos a
dibujarlo por aquí recuerden que estos
orbitales están formando un tetra
ebro en la tercera dimensión digamos que
este orbital está metido en la pantalla
hacia el fondo y estos dos orbitales
están como que está saliendo hacia
nosotros y nos falta otro orbital por
aquí que es así podemos pensar que está
dentro de la pantalla
puedes pensarlo como que esto es un
tripié acostado y vamos a dibujar al
otro carbono con sus orbitales en forma
de triple
y ahora vamos a dibujar los orbitales de
los hidrógenos cada uno de estos está
haciendo un enlace con tres hidrógenos y
los hidrógenos tienen un solo orbital
que es un orbital de tipo s que es un
orbital esférico entonces tenemos por
aquí los tres hidrógenos de este carbono
y los otros tres hidrógenos de este otro
carbono y entonces si queremos contar
todos los enlaces sigma de esta molécula
pues tenemos que fijarnos en donde se
intersectan estos orbitales y si esta
intersección se da como que entre los
núcleos de los dos átomos como es el
caso aquí está el núcleo del núcleo y
esta intersección está en medio entonces
este es un enlace sigma así es que pues
este también es un enlace sigma al igual
que éste
y pues todos estos enlaces también son
enlaces sigma porque se encuentran entre
los dos núcleos de los átomos así es que
tenemos siete enlaces sigma otra cosa
muy importante que hay que decir acerca
del etano es que como tiene un solo
enlace entre estos dos carbono y bueno
como es un solo enlace es un enlace de
signo entonces esta molécula puede girar
en este eje digamos podemos dejar este
átomo fijo tal cual con este hidrógeno
aquí este aquí ya esta otra acá y esta
otra molécula puede girar todo lo que
quiera entonces dependiendo de como gire
esta molécula se puede formar un isómero
con formación al pero bueno el chiste es
que estos enlaces sigma en estos enlaces
simples permiten una rotación de estos
átomos aunque otra cosa que es
importante decir aquí también es que
este enlace entre estos carbonos se está
haciendo con dos orbitales híbridos sp3
los orbitales híbridos que vamos a ver
varios en esta sección
estos orbitales híbridos sp3 son los más
largos de todos que hay porque tienen
más componente del orbital p y los
orbitales p son los que son alargados
como mancuernas y los orbitales s son
mucho menos largos son como esferas y
entonces cómo estos orbitales son más
largos estas moléculas de carbono están
más separadas y bueno cuando tenemos
enlaces dobles o enlaces triples lo que
sucede es que vamos a dejar por ahí un
orbital p solito y vamos a mezclar con
el orbitales menos orbitales pes y por
lo tanto las órbitas híbridas s
o sp2 van a ser más cortas porque van a
tener más del orbital ese y por eso es
que los enlaces simples que son los que
utilizan los orbitales híbridos sp3 son
más largos que los enlaces dobles o
enlaces triples pero bueno todo eso lo
vamos a ver con detalle en los próximos
vídeos